كان حيا لكنهم
اعدموه لخصت هذه اللقطات سلسله اعدامات
ميدانيه الشهيد رامي العبوشي اصيب برصاص
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في مخيم الفارعه ثم
تسابق الجنود الى اطلاق النار عليه وهو
ملقا على الارض بعد ذلك عمدوا الى اعدام
جاره ثائر اثناء احتماء من الرصاص في
المكان
ذاته
رحمه الله عليك يا
اخوي يراجع اهله المشاهد لقطه بلقطه
وبزوايا مختلفه يبحثون عن عذر او مبرر
لقتله بدم بارد هكذا دون تشكيل اي نوع من
انواع الخطر فلا يجدون دم الشيد رام
يحرقهم القهر وهم ينظرون الى اللحظات
الاخيره لابنائهم الابرياء
ويفاجئهم اصرار قاتلهم على توثيق فعلته
ايضا
كل من كان حينها يشهد على واقع ممارسات
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المستحدثه بحق
الفلسطينيين خلال اقتحامات لمدنهم
ومخيماتها الجبات اثنين من هون مسرعات
معهم رشاشه توماتيك طخو بالرشاش الوماتيك
الحساسه طبعهم بعد ما رموه هون لف الجب
عليه فتح الباب وكمل عليه تطخ 14 طلقه كان
عايش كان عايش كان الولد عايش ما في في شي
بالمره بق الطلقه سبطه اول طلقه كانت يعني
مع الكتب عن طريق الرشاش الاوتوماتيك لكن
لما فتح الباب كمل عليه وعاش بقدر الجندي
الاسرائيلي يمسكه بيده هيك وياخذه لو بده
ياخذه لو بده يعدمه بس هم هدفهم الاول
والاخير
الاعدام تزداد قوائم الشهداء يوميا في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله احنا الان نواجه
عدو مجرم نازي يستهدف ابنائنا واطفالنا
ويقوم بقتل لهم بدم بارد وهذا تعبير عن
فشله في قطاع غزه وما يواجهه من
المقاومه ليست حادثه منفصله فقبل بايام
فقط كانت كاميرات المراقبه في جنين قد
وثقت مشاهد مشابهه لاعدام جنود الاحتلال
طفلين ميدانيا بل تصويرهم بعد قتلهم ايضا
تتكرر الحالات نتيجه لغياب المحاسبه في
راي حقوقيين ما
يتم جرائم وب انتهاكات هي مشرعه من قبل
القانون الاسرائيلي في اوامر اطلاق النار
بتسمح باطلاق النار به الطريقه ايام قليله
ويتكرر المشهد في الفارعه مجددا لم توثقه
الكاميرات هذه المره انما عيون طفل نجى من
الموت لم يرد ان يظهرها امام العدسات تؤكد
استمرار مسلسل تعمد قتل
الفلسطينيين كنا واقفين انا والشهيد جزن
الخطيب غ عند السياره الحمراء صار يطخ
علينا الجندي ظلينا نركض نركض نركض وصلنا
لهون صابه يزن براسه وانا صابوني بايدي
سحبته جوا سحبته عند هون اه بس بكش في
كاميرا تصور اللي صار لما اختاره الشهيد
جزن الخطيب لولا وجود مثل هذه الكاميرات
امام منازل الفلسطينيين لما كشفت جرائم
الاعدام الميداني بحق ابنائهم كما اخفيت
جرائم كثيره اخرى اثناء اقتحامات قوات
الاحتلال المتكرره لمدن الضفه الغربيه
ومخيماتها في كل مره لا يختلف سوى اسم
الشهيد ومكان استشهاده لكن الفاعل يبقى
واحدا حسن مسعود ال الجزيره من مخيم
الفارعه شمال الضفه الغربيه